welcome back guys we're up to episode 18
in this little demo rpg series here with
c plus plus and we are going to work on
equipping and using these items that you
can now pick up from monsters that drop
him that's going to be mainly this
episode because right where we left off
here he could move over the monster and
attack it
and fight it and you get some inventory
stuff looks like we found some boots but
now uh since we kind of see how to make
items and how to put them in your
inventory that's all well and good
but now how to use them what do you do
with these items how to use these
potions that's what we're going to try
to figure out in this episode so stay
tuned and you'll learn a few things
and it looks like we're going to have to
make some edits to our library in order
for this to work because currently the
only way we have to look at the items
in our characters backpack is with this
whole get backpack list and this if we
go look at it
it returns a const vector pointer of
items and while these pointers were will
point to the actual data since it's
const we're not allowed to touch it or
modify it or do anything with it so
we're looking at the actual items that's
good but we're gonna this is a copy list
so we're getting a copy of pointers and
a vector anytime we call this get
backpack list and since it's const we're
just
we're just kind of stuck there uh only
be able to look at it but we want to be
able to call things like equip
so if we go look at equip which i
believe we have in our item manager
yes there it is equip
we need a pointer to the item to equip
and the character
so if we go look at this function we got
to analyze what it does because this is
going to get a little tricky and we
might have to make some major edits to
the library if this doesn't work well at
first so we will just have to kind of
see
so let's assume that we try to equip a
piece of armor what's gonna happen what
should happen well
what should happen is it should move out
of the character's backpack so it should
be removed from that list
and then the item should now be equipped
to the character so it'll basically be
on a separate list or separate area if
we go look at our player characters we
can see where we have
this it is a private
equipped armor array
equal to the number of slots possible
armor slots so this is where the item is
going to be stored yet this is going to
be control who uh owns it basically and
who
now has control over what happens to it
but since we have an item manager
we are basically delegating all that
responsibility into these item manager
functions and it's a little complicated
and maybe there's a better way to do it
but this works for now so what we're
going to do in this case is we're
basically just going to go ahead and
just equip it or use and then
we'll see what happens and we'll sort
out any problems now i kind of know
what's already going to happen but just
to see this live might be helpful to
some people uh says i made changes here
i didn't mean to let's not save that but
one of the things we really need here is
we need a way to actually select the
items or to say which one we're using or
equipping so in other words this
function is about to get really really
messy and let's let's go ahead and
analyze here so this function currently
is responsible for displaying the
inventory basically it's got a clear
screen so we get a new screen it's the
list shows the list and then we can just
exit but what we want to do instead is
we do want to show the list but we also
want to have some sort of cursor so that
we can select things from the list and
we're going to have to do this through a
loop
so essentially we are going to put this
in a while loop
and we'll say not done so i'm going to
make a boolean here just a local one all
done set it to false
while not done so why we're not done
with the inventory we're going to go
through this loop
of
displaying the inventory and then
waiting for a character now the waiting
for a character is really important
because it's going to stop the loop
after every reveal and basically we're
going to make like a little cursor that
lets you flip through the list of stuff
and choose things
and also when we do this every time we
need to do this we probably need to
re-grab the list
and make sure it's the same which is
going to be a lot of copying and a bit
messy so we'll analyze that as we go
let's go ahead and just try some stuff
but first of all we only want this
little highlight cursor here probably on
the item that's selected so we need to
keep track of that
so we need to keep track of that
somewhere like up here so end
selected item
number
we'll start it out as zero which will
essentially be the first one so we need
to keep a count here as well whereas
we're going through this loop um well
we'll make it an integer
auto
item
it's called item counts or call it items
in backpack
count
kind of a long name but at least it's
clear and as we go through this list
we'll just iterate and uh plus this up
basically
now every time we restart this while
loop this is going to reinitialize and
be zero again
that's important because we're also
going to keep track of which one's
selected based on which item it is in
the backpack it's going to be a little a
little weird to wrap your head around at
first maybe
but it'll make sense as we go here
because basically we want to say
basically we want to control where this
cursor is with this sort of thing
so we can say if selected item num is
equal to
items in backpack count
basically it's which one we're currently
on we can just do a tab over here
and then we'll put
that little cursor thing else no cursor
so we'll just make it two blank spaces
now maybe we can clean this up a little
bit and just make it a little ternary
operator let's see if this works
this might not work because i think it
looks for a return value here let's
let's just see what happens
is it happy with this line of code
apparently it
isn't
i don't know i have to look out
i think you need to
you only use ternary operators when you
return stuff i forget off the top of my
head if someone wants to leave a comment
about that that'd be sweet because i'm
not gonna go look it up right now
although you know that's what you
generally do all right but we'll just
make it
four lines of code to do that to display
the right cursor so we can get rid of
this cursor here
because we already have this
handling on which one is selected
and that should take care of it
now if we run this right now should put
a cursor on the first one
but only if it even goes into this loop
so if there's no items it's not really
going to do anything
it should be fine
and we need this character to handle
whether we're done or not so we're going
to have to work with that we'll just for
now we're just going to go if we no
longer need this press enter to continue
we'll just say fc
is equal to
i guess
d
yeah we'll use d for done
um let me think about this actually
let's let's say something here at the
bottom should not do a bunch of times
so we'll just put some little
notifications for the player here d
equals
done
and we can you know we can put any other
options here
like w equals up
s equals down
and maybe we can say like u equals use
slash equip
current okay that's that's enough let's
work with that right now so let's make a
little switch statement here i guess
since we have some pretty well defined
options
so we switch on c case of the d
character
we will return or actually i guess we'd
say
done
equals true so it'll not go through the
loop anymore make sure we break
uh case w then we go item
selected
uh minus minus
but we also want to make sure it
doesn't go below zero so we want to
check that now we'll just do a quick if
selected item number less than zero then
just set it to zero
and anything else we need to do here no
i don't think so break and we can do a
very similar thing for down
except okay when you change this to s we
need to change this to plus plus
and now we need to check if it's greater
than the total number of items in the
list so we'll take this list of items
dot size is fine
but we need to minus one it because the
list is going to start at zero so the
selected item number
because this size is going to return
for example
uh i'll just say this directly in case
you're not aware
say you have three items in your
backpack they're gonna be labeled item
zero one and two
so it'll be like zero one two three
items but if you try to select
like literally item three it doesn't
exist because three is a two since it
starts at zero so that's why you got to
do a minus one on this size because
sizes are gonna return three but three
is not valid because things start at one
or zero things start at zero all right
so
you probably already know that but i'll
just say it again just to be sure
um yeah so if it's greater than that
then we'll just set it to that and there
we go that just makes sure we can't go
off our list
and let's do the last case here of the
you character
and in this case we just want to call
use on that item so it'll be
item manager well we're going to decide
if it's
you know
equipment
or potion
so equip only works
on items
so we i guess we could do a cast check
here yeah i guess we gotta do that
so if uh we'll just do an if a quick if
here we only need to do one check item
manager
if it is a potion we gotta tell it which
one we're passing in
it is gonna be list of items
at the selected one selected item num
[Music]
yep that's the one that returns true
then it's a potion if it doesn't return
true well there's only one other option
right now and
that is that it's
armor or something
but both of these are basically the same
we just
do use on this one
doesn't like something about this
use requires the character to be passed
in as well
okay we'll go ahead and do that main
character
dot us
and it wants it as what let's look at
this again
it wants it as a pointer so we have to
make a reference to that variable
we just thought you would let's look at
it again
player character
use once player character pointer okay
yeah that should be reference to it
yeah
that's uh okay why is this not happy
oh it's just player we need player
character so that's a little further
down in this which isn't get data i
believe is that right let's look at it
let's look at player character player
character delegate
no this should be right this should be
fine i guess do we need to
do this sort of thing oh this is a
okay
yeah it's a pointer here so we need to
go like so there we go
that's the one
just straighten that up a little bit
there we go got a little case there
and we can do a break at the end now
equip once the same thing doesn't yeah
once a player character basically
because it needs to manage that backpack
of the character at least i believe that
was the intention we were going for i'm
not expecting these use and equip to
work correctly right now but basically
because this list of items is const so
we're probably it's probably going to
throw an error at some point here but we
at least want to give it a try and see
what happens and let's make the last
default case here
which is just going to be break so now
we should have a way to
select
the items it's going to be represented
by this cursor
and we have a way to
attempt to use the current item that's
selected
is this going to work correctly
we're about to find out i'm totally
expecting a crash but let's go ahead and
do a quick battle we've got a warning
there but no crashes yet it's probably
going to be run time crashes and i think
you can cue up movements yeah you can
okay sweet because we're not clear in
the stream so
that's a thing we got a potion of
healing okay let's go into our inventory
and we've got the
potion selected let's attempt to use it
with you okay
well it did
it crashed eventually all right
so yeah that was kind of expected the
first time it didn't crash though the
second time
well there was nothing actually there
that was the problem so
that was kind of expected because we
used the first one so it's it kind of
makes sense that it was gone but however
we don't refresh our list of items here
in this current so what we actually want
to do is take this list and re-grab it
anytime we restart this list
it's kind of a heavy function but it's
just a list of pointers it's not that
much memory so we're not going to worry
about it too much it's not going to
cause any noticeable
issues go ahead and battle this first
monster we got a potion of healing let's
go to our inventory
and go ahead and use that potion and it
now is gone so that's good so if we hit
any of these up we gotta assert if you
try to use with an empty inventory so
let's straighten that out real quick
uh yeah so
we will need to make a case here that
basically says
uh if the list of items is empty
just empty
then what we need to do is actually
continue which basically means
uh start at the while loop again so it's
just going to go back to the top of the
while loop at this continue so that
should fix that empty case
let's go ahead and do another battle
cue up the movements that's actually
really handy received breastplate
excellent
all right let's see what happens here
use equip we equip but it's still there
so that means it's not working properly
let's try to equip again now we got two
breastplates we're duping items now we
got three this is fun we have now duped
a bunch of breastplates so that's a
that's a fun bug
so now we just have to analyze why is
that happening it's probably this equip
function and it's what this equip
function does i think
it's not coming out of the inventory so
it's equipping the first time and just
staying in the inventory and the problem
with that is well now you've got two of
them one equipped and one your inventory
so every time you try to equip again it
takes your current one off puts it in
your inventory and whatever one you put
on it puts on so we're just ending up
with another one every time we equip
over top
and uh the main reason is is because
we're not removing it from our backpack
when we equip
now the reality is these are probably
pointers to all the same data too so
it's not actually duplicating the item
i'm pretty sure we're just duplicating
the pointer so we're just getting a
bunch of pointers
to the same item so we need to analyze
why this is happening
we are calling this move to backpack
whenever we equip an old one but when we
equip a fresh one
we don't really say where it's coming
from we just say equip
we just say that it's now equipped
so what we actually need to do is
either call delete item or remove from
backpack or make some sort of function
that basically moves it out of your
backpack
so
let's go ahead and make that let's see
what we got currently see if we have any
current solutions
we don't actually want to delete the
item because delete would be like fully
remove the data we probably just want
remove from backpack so let's make a
function for that static
i guess we'll make it void remove from
backpack
i guess we'll go player character
because they have the backpack
now let's go ahead and make this
function
in our cpp control alt
home to open that file and here we go
so we've got these internal functions
that we were using we have this move to
backpack internal function that this one
used
and i guess we want to do a summary
thing here we're going to make sure all
this stuff is actually
exists let's go bowl here
actually instead so just back to that
just so we can return true and false
here
fix the name
now we've got to think about what we
want this to do
let's look at our move to backpack
function and see what we were doing
there we were just doing a pushback
so basically i think what we want to do
is just mark
mark it for deletion and then call this
cleanup backpack function
however this is a little dangerous
because in this function we use delete
item and this actually deletes the data
we don't want to necessarily delete the
data unless
we know that it's the items basically
destroyed
so this cleanup backpack actually
destroys items but if it's equipped we
don't want it destroyed because it still
exists on the character we just don't
want it in our list
so it's a little bit of a different case
here but i think we can use something
pretty similar yeah we can't just
mark it for deletion
we have a couple different ways we could
go about doing this we could make a
a mark that says it's equipped and
instead of deleting we could do
something else
oh design decisions
what i really want to happen here
is i want it to well what's really
throwing me for a bit of a loop here is
i'm trying to plan ahead for the future
because if you open let's say you open a
treasure chest at some point in the game
and it is just
you know it's it's items you should in
theory be able to equip from that
treasure
chest
and in that case you don't want to
reference to the character for a quip
you want to reference to
the bag which would be a vector of items
basically or pointers to items so maybe
we should modify this move to back or
this equip
to take something else too like
um
may or we could just say no you have to
move it to your bag first then you can
equip it or you have to move to your
backpack first then you can equip it so
we have to decide which of those is
better for us and i think i'm just gonna
for simplicity's sake say we have
to move it to your backpack first before
you can equip it no equipping straight
out of the chest or whatever i think
that makes sense in a lot of ways
because
yeah you actually need to pull it into
your inventory before you can do stuff
with it and that's just a design
decision really
we wanted it to be more open we could
design in a way where you could just use
stuff from anywhere
but i haven't really designed for that
and it's going to be some pretty big
changes to do that so let's just keep it
simple
i think the simplest way to do it is to
just put the code right here under this
fresh equip
that gets rid of whatever you just
equipped
but only out of our array
so it's going to be very similar to our
cleanup backpack method which is where
are you
and in fact i think the easiest way to
do this is to
change the skip this whole get marked
for deletion
setup so maybe we'll just call clean up
backpack
more frequently basically here
and we'll update this function to yes
get rid of things that are marked for
deletion but also
to get rid of but not delete things that
are marked as
just equipped
so let's make a few changes here
welcome to game development where you
get hung up on little problems for an
extreme amount of time
so this is this is the reality of of
game dev sometimes you spend a lot of
time figuring out a little stuff like
this
i think it's important to show so
hopefully you're appreciating this
but basically what we're going to do
here is just go to our item
and go to where we have marked for
deletion and just update this a little
bit
and just
mark this just equipped started out as
false
make it getter
now of course the item manager
can change these values so we'll be able
to update this value as needed
let's make this a little more clear and
rather than marked as just equipped
marked
as
ref needs removed
marked as backpack ref gone so there we
go i know that's a really confusing
thing to say but
it works
now as uh if you think about these
we should really be using unique
pointers basically well maybe not even
unique pointers yeah we should be using
unique pointers and we should be passing
off ownership of this pointer that way
we basically cannot make mistakes
because the code literally won't let us
and that's one of the advantages
of unique pointers
but we haven't done that and that would
be a whole refactor
the reason i didn't do it is basically i
wanted to show you how to use raw
pointers but now it's coming back to
bite me a little bit but it's not too
bad we just have to really think about
it carefully and we're not going to get
compiler errors if we mess up this logic
uh that's that's the
so yeah that's the huge advantage you
get compiler errors if you mess up your
logic when you're using unique pointers
and that's what you want because you'd
rather have a compiler error than a
crash later when you ship it to your
customer
or something like that
it marked as
ref gone
okay there we go
okay so now when we go to equip it
we need to just mark it as the ref is
gone and then call clean up
backpack
now do we need to do it to both of these
so
if something's already equipped we move
whatever they currently had equipped to
the backpack we take the old one we put
it on and then we need to yeah we need
to remove that ref
so we go yeah the same function here
i guess we could even use the same
pointer here
item two equipped
march is back backpack ref gone true
backpack ref gone true if we equip it
fresh and then right here we need to
call that cleanup backpack method on our
character and that should take care of
it we need to update this function and
take care of it
get rid of pointers and backpack
that
are now
whipped okay very good
so this clean up backpack let's go to it
and sure we have this method which is
fine and we also have we're going to
make another version of it that is get
marked as repton and we don't want to
delete these is the thing
so we'll just get rid of that all we
need to do is call erase to get rid of
the pointer
so we no longer need to call this whole
functionality here just a simple erase
should be enough so we can get rid of
that all together and we'll call this to
remove ref to remove ref
now the thing we should do before we
actually remove these
is we should update it
because this status
of uh
marked as backpack ref gone
we no longer need it
once we have equipped the item so
actually let's go ahead and use this for
each but instead of deleting the item
let's just update it
[Music]
let's see what are we doing here
i
dot
um we don't have access okay yeah we
don't have access to the item here we'd
have to use the item manager because uh
well we're in player character here
in player character it's not allowed to
actually edit these items private data
like the item manager is so we have to
do it maybe a slightly different way
and i have an idea here
let's let's let it keep its value of
backpack ref gone and let's just go into
our equip and this whole move to
backpack thing here
this is the one
where this is where we want to remove
that old ref so let's just do it before
we move it to our backpack let's just
call
this a marked as backpack rep gone
equals false
there we go so we'll just flip it back
before we put it back in our inventory
and that should make sure it doesn't
have any errors
we essentially need to do the same thing
for weapons so this code is going to be
very similar
so let's just copy it down we're going
to have to change this to equipped
weapon yo
[Music]
that's fine and same thing down here
and we need to also call this
if item fails to equip move it to the
character's backpack uh we're not sure
if we're gonna use that this might
actually cause a bit of a bug because
let's think about it the reason this was
in here is in case you tried to call
equip on potions
which you maybe will just not allow
maybe instead of that whole thing
happening
like if you try to equip a potion maybe
it just does not that'll be better so
let's go back to our item manager
and let's just
take a quick peek at this equip method
where it is there we are okay chase what
are you doing phone settled down
that was the most useless alert ever
extended warranty
no thanks how about i mute my phone
much better
so i think what we're going to do here
is just a quick check on the item so
we'll just go
is
item potion
and if it is we're just going to return
false no moving to backpack
and we could do the same thing on
this here or do we already do that let's
let's check well we do but this is kind
of messy
oh cast item to potion
oh well we're not going to worry about
that we'll see if we don't have any bugs
we're not going to change it because
when you try to analyze everything in
your whole code base when you make one
change it just becomes overwhelming
let's just see if our items now equip
correctly as we're intending
okay let's go ahead and
battle this bad boy we received some
boots excellent let's go into our
inventory and equip those boots
nice
okay
uh now let's just see what happens if we
hit the equip button again nothing
perfect now we probably want a clear
screen at the end of at each of these
because that's looking a little messy so
let's just go ahead and do that we're
just going to take this clear and put it
at the top of this while loop instead
very well
okay so now we can use and equip items
however it doesn't give you armor or
anything like that for your items yet so
we do need to update that real quick
and just make it actually do something
now if you equip weapons you should do
more damage
but currently with armor you don't take
any less damage so on this fight
sequence let's just put in a little
logic here that makes you take
a little less damage if you're armored
because i feel like that's going to be
quite current so reducing the monsters
hp that's fine but reducing rhp well we
just take we just flat out take the
attack damage
but let's just subtract this
let's put a whole formula in here before
this whole take damage thing let's get
the
let's make a unsigned int i suppose here
you and 32 damage
taken actually let's make it an ant now
ant damage we also call damage we take
and let's put a whole formula in here
so first of all let's get the monster's
attack damage and let's just minus this
down by our armor damage we take
minus equals our armor
so let's go player one dot us dot get
total armor there we go
and we want this to be at least one
because well
the damage we take
is uh less than zero when you hit here
so
we want to take at least one damage if
we hit basically now it depends on your
design what you want to do you can say
maybe you have so much armor that takes
zero damage but we can't take negative
damage that doesn't make any sense so
actually i guess this would be less than
one we're going to say you at least take
one damage no matter what and there we
go
but at least now
if we get late in the game the monsters
are hitting you for like 40 damage but
you've got 40 armor you only only take
one so it's probably going to be a
little unbalanced to start we're
probably going to be just flat out too
strong right now once we start equipping
stuff but currently our monsters if we
go look at them
monsters don't have any armor or any
stats really to speak of other than hp
and damage
so we're gonna have to expand monster at
some point and give them armor as well
so it becomes a little more balanced out
and we're gonna have to do some number
tweaking to make sure things are sorted
out
and the way we've designed things and
the way they're hard-coded the numbers
are all in different files and all over
the place it might actually be a good
idea here really soon to make
files that we pull from that just have
all our data so we can just like
you know fill out one little chart of
how everybody's stuff is
and uh then it'll all be in one place
and we can load it at run time
so there's stuff like that we can do to
clean it up but right now we're just
gonna have to go to these individual
files and modify things i'm not sure if
we'll have enough time to get to
cleaning up a lot of stuff we're still
just of course hacking it together
overall though it looks like things are
working pretty good let's just play for
a while and see if we can get some good
battling in
okay battle this guy
he's hitting us for two a lot of times
we have a ring very nice let's go to our
inventory and equip that ring get out of
the inventory we also need a way to look
at our current equipment that would be
nice
this monster dropped nothing
let's fight this one
we shouldn't be taking too much oh we
might die on this one oh we barely won
we got a potion of healing perfect we're
surviving let's see if this potion works
use
done
okay now we have another problem we
don't really okay we have seven hp and
reverse of monster does seven damage
i think we're going to lose we needed a
weapon you were defeated by the monster
total monsters defeated three not bad
though as you can see we got some more
stuff going on and it's getting them
getting to be a little more interactive
we're starting to actually have a few
choices
so that is really good there's so much
stuff to do there's so much i want to do
so much i'm excited to do but we just
don't have time
if you want me to spend more time on
this uh consider signing up on the
patreon or leaving a thanks or doing
some any sort of monetary donation helps
a lot because as you might understand or
maybe you don't understand so i'll just
let you know directly these take a lot
of time
and money to produce
and i make very little off of them
that's why i can't do it forever and i'm
limiting myself to a certain area but i
do like teaching and passing stuff along
but if you want to see more and see me
go further consider doing something now
of course likes and subs all that helps
too but really as far as recommending
the series goes it's all about watch
time so basically people have to
actually watch the whole thing for it to
get recommended so uh
yeah the series is still gonna fall off
if you just leave a like and then leave
immediately it's only gonna the series
is only actually gonna take off on
youtube if people actually watch the
whole thing so there i've said all that
but we're gonna do one last thing and
that's just display some stats on our
character just like a character sheet
type of thing because i think that's
kind of critical
so let's just make us a little character
sheet we'll just make a function for
this
and then we'll just go void and display
character sheet
that way we can tell our stats and all
that good stuff in our armor and what's
equipped and everything
our character should probably have a
name but we don't have names yet so
we're just going to have we'll show
class and level and stats and equip
stuff and that should be good for now
so we'll start out with a clear screen
and we already have access to our player
since it's global so we don't need to
pass in access or anything like that so
let's just go ahead and start printing
stuff first of all we're just going to
say your character at the top let's do
these little lines
i think i'm just going to use a single c
out at the top and we'll just do
everything
in one big format now let's go let's say
hp first
i'm not really doing mp yet so we're
just going to leave that off pretty much
just going to stick to a core system
here
there's the hp line
now let's just do some strength and
stuff actually let's just let's show
damage
in armor
i feel like those are the most relevant
things you'll probably want to see
rather than attack damage let's just say
80 now maybe maybe we will spell it out
let's just be real clear we don't
actually have a great way of showing the
damage right now because it's all
calculated with attack
so you basically have to do an attack
but you get a random value so that's not
good we could check the weapon
and then check the damage on the weapon
but what if the weapons null this
actually is
we don't really have this functionality
built in well so we're gonna have to
leave the attack damage off let's just
put in
armor here
instead because this we have a nice
function for
and that is just get total armor gonna
total up
everything of course we have base armor
which we could show if we want but we
really want to see all our armor here
and maybe in this same line
we'll just make a couple spaces over and
go
resistance
i think that's how you spell resistance
and same thing here except get total
resistance then a new line character at
the end
let's just go ahead and display strength
same thing here except get total
strength
or whatever i named this function yet
oh and main character spelled wrong
oh i need
need some carrots there
my phones would just be quiet that would
be great
all right we're just going to do this
for all these
maybe i'll just
yeah we're going to capitalize these
stats copy paste action
there we go we got all the stats there
get total and intellect and new line at
the end there
and now we just want to display
our equipped stuff so
let's just make another area
or equipped
this is going to be a little bit
trickier because some of these could be
null and if they're null we want to
basically display nothing so now what we
want to do is we want to call get
equipped at and if it's no we want to
say nothing otherwise we want to have
something
so this is going to be a little tricky
but i think we're just going to do it
all in one big line and we're going to
use our function main character
we have a function for this already us
get equipped at so let's look at get
equipped equipped weapon hat
and we need weapon slot melee now this
wants to be cast to a unsigned long long
there's a way to make these not unsigned
long longs i think you set the last
value to like
some certain number and it'll make them
a smaller one uh
yeah if you know leave a comment
so this returns
a weapon pointer and we're gonna just
design some logic in here so we're gonna
need a fresh cl so let's let's see about
melee weapon
so let's just make a string real quick
here let's just do a demo of maybe one
of that should work
looks ugly but this should return a
weapon well if this is null it's gonna
crash that's that's the problem here so
we need like it is weapon equipped which
you know this kind of is a check
but
we could make it like a boolean
it's messier and messier the further we
go his weapon equipped we'll just get
the weapon guess we need to do an if
statement here get equipped weapon at
so it's either going to be true or false
and if it's true
we have a weapon equipped otherwise we
don't so
there we go let's just comment the rest
of these out for now
let's see if we can get this weapon one
to work properly first pointer to a
bound function may only be used to call
the function oh
these shouldn't be brackets
there
yeah just doing the brackets wrong
i was doing it like this was an array
but no this
function is what goes into the array and
does all the work so we just need to
pass it the number
like so okay there we go that should
that should do the weapon so we could do
this for all of them
basically uh sure now that we've done
one it's not too bad to do the rest just
need to uh
propagate this
down and we'll just call this
weapon name weapon name we're going to
shadow the variables because who cares
right now we're just being quick about
it
so if we look at these basically it
checks if something's there because if
this is null it will not go into the if
state it's not null then we it will go
in there
and that way it uh you know it gets the
name
we don't want to try to get the name if
it's no because it's going to crash
there we go there's melee and ranged
excellent so now we can do this for all
the armors and now that we're copying
and pasting it should be pretty quick
change this to armor slot
change this to get equipped armor
that change this to armor name
change this to head slot
change that that slot use this to armor
slots
okay there we go got the head but now
this is only going to show
if you've actually got something
equipped there
okay but that's fine and now that we've
done one of the armor ones we can just
copy this neck into all of them
there's probably a faster more modular
way of doing this but at this point i
just want to get it done
oh the power of copy paste
okay that actually looks pretty good
let's have a quick scan and make sure
everything looks good make sure we
didn't mess up and say the wrong thing
anywhere yeah looks fine
all right so that just displays our
character sheets going to show our hip
points armor
stats and our equipped gear
i think that's
yeah that's pretty much enough uh now
that we're showing equipped gear we
could pretty easily
put the damage in here
so let's just do that real quick
so if we've got that then we've also got
min damage
we've also got
the max damage
so we can just paste that in there real
quick that'll at least be something
that we've got some way to see our
damage say the weapon name
and let's see
let's say damage i'm just going to put a
d there and put it in parentheses
close it off
put a new line
okay so now our melee shows the damage i
guess we could put it for the range as
well and for the armor we could show the
armor stats but that's
that's up to
a longer implementation
and honestly this is terrible practice
because we're calling these same getters
over and over or in reality is we should
just cache the variable that would make
a lot more sense
but yeah i'm not going to show all the
stats of all this stuff we've done
enough
done enough it's it's messy
but it should work so now we just need a
way to call this function display
character sheet and at the end we want
to hold just like we do with the rest of
these functions little press enter to
continue type of thing
which will be done like this let's just
put that at the bottom
and let's change this to press enter to
continue
all right let's collapse these down so
we can see what's going on a little bit
and now
if this all works good we're ready to
change these random drops and make it a
little cooler because right now it's
just very
basic
okay so let's scroll on down to where we
have our main controls for where our
main world and now let's just put a new
case in here
for character sheet
we'll say c
let's just put a case in here for that
we need to break here case
c
display character cheat
and break all right let's have a look at
that
make sure it all builds make our warrior
let's go ahead and move let's fight a
monster first we're pretty confident we
can defeat at least one monster although
it's kicking our butt we lost a lot of
hp we got some leg guards though so
that's nice let's go to our inventory
there's our leg guards equip that get
out of here go to our character sheet
there's our character looks like we've
says our hit points we've now got one
armor see our strength and everything we
got and then it shows our equipped gear
uh i feel like we need a space before
the equip gear but you can see we got
legs leg guards and it works pretty fine
let's go ahead and hit enter here
uh let's try battling another monster he
shouldn't hit quite as hard now that
we've got some leg guards yeah he
shouldn't be able to hit us for two
anymore but hopefully we get a potion of
healing nope just a ring i don't know if
that's gonna be enough to save us but
we'll equip it
and uh get out of here and check out our
character sheet and looks like we got a
ring equipped and
we got some buff stats the rings give
plus one to all stats right now so we
see that that is uh raised as intended
so that's all working
pretty cool stuff all right let's see if
we can manage to defeat another monster
i don't think we'll be able to he's
going to kill us
we can still barely get uh
two to three monsters killed but if we
get lucky and the monsters drop a lot of
potions we should be able to continue on
so basically you have to get really
lucky right now and have them drop
potions
maybe we should have some kind of heal
mechanic where you automatically heal a
little bit after every fight or
something um
well that's optional but now anytime we
want to edit one of these we can just go
in here i'm going to put a couple line
breaks before this equipped gear
that way it's a little more clear
and i'm gonna uncapitalize it
and i think i'm just gonna get rid of
this
little thing all together there we go
that should probably be enough for this
episode let me go ahead and just address
any issues we have real quick here
there's one
possible loss of data
oh we just want to cast this to an
integer
i think that's all we need here oops
yeah that's good enough
all right well that's it for this
episode hope you enjoyed let me know
what you think down below
it's getting pretty interesting it's
it's actually uh we're starting to get
somewhere we're starting to get to a
place where like we can progress
basically
we're gonna have to kill a lot of
monsters to level up but once we're
leveling up you know you will have to
flesh out the leveling systems a little
more god i can't
i can't beat this guy oh i should have
equipped my item or used my item
and i probably would have beat him
but that's the way the cookie crumbles
alright thanks for watching see you guys
next time peace out
[Music]
you